c'est officiel geneviève de fontenay est
en guerre contre miss france et compte
bien le faire savoir
après avoir expliqué à plusieurs
reprises qu'il était honteux que sylvie
tellier ne vais pas invité pour
organiser à ses côtés le 100e
anniversaire de la création du concours
aujourd'hui la dame au chapeau raconte
avec émotion cette trahison la poète
tornade
elle veut elle veut briller il se met en
valeur c'est dans une émouvante lettre
transmise à jean marc morandini que
geneviève explique j'ai tout donné à
miss france tout sacrifier pour ce
concours je suis triste de ne pas avoir
été contactée pour participer à l'
ouvrage sur les 100 ans du concours
triste de ne pas avoir pu mettre ma
touche dans ce centenaire dans cette
lettre à coeur ouvert celle qui fête
cette année ses 88 ans explique avec
mélancolie à look de nos centenaires et
alors que ma santé décline peu à peu je
regarderai l'élection à jamais pour
l'éternité
les miss france d'hier et de demain ce
seront mes miss parce que j'aime
profondément ce concours auquel j'ai
donné ma vie si geneviève de fontenay
explique elle regardera l'élection son
attaché de presse nous a confié qu'elle
avait en réalité l'intention de
boycotter l'émission une cérémonie
anniversaire qui représente trop de
souvenirs pour elle alors boycott
descente en miss france par geneviève de
fontenay
comprenez vous sa décision
alors comprenez vous cette décision oui
non oui non oui non oui non non pour
nathalie pourquoi alors vous serez vous
serez dans le jury pour les jouets pour
l'élection de miss france je suis très
fier très contente
non franchement même de fond d'elle me
fatigue là j'en ai marre j'en ai marre
parce qu'elle est tout le temps en train
de râler pour râler on l'invité en tant
que présidente pour le comité pour le
jury de miss france alors fusé on a
invité pour pour toutes les invitations
qu'on lui donne elle les refusent quand
on a fait les photos des miss laisse le
centenaire sylvie tellier se prenait la
tête toute la journée pour essayer de la
rappeler pour la faire venir son plateau
en mettant pour le tour qu'on est pour
les sanitaires le maquillage spécial
pour l mac à un taxi enfin tout la
totale elle refuse elle est tout le
temps en train de pleurer pleurer
pleurer je pense que à 88 ans elle a
déjà beaucoup de chance d'avoir eu
l'argent qu'elle a eu déjà en vente dans
le sable à 10 millions c'est 10 millions
d'euros à la 6 millions paraît-il pour
le fils et sa répartie problème pour les
enfants elle a révélé que le regarder
que 1 million il faut pas s il faut pas
aussi oublier qu'en 2011 après qu'elle a
quittée miss france
elle a monté les laisserons de mystery
jets à l'essai de le faire à l'envers
exactement à l'envers c'est pas cool
elle a mis d'ailleurs comme présidente
la miss france 1968 et d'ailleurs elle
fait pris la tête aussi avec parce
qu'elle demandait trop d'argent par
rapport aux candidats aux candidates
donc elle est partie elle part toujours
le là où on invite elle paraît
disparaissent que vous avez le sentiment
nathalie que finalement elle ne fait que
ça que pour faire parler d'elle et que
finalement c'est exactement ça une miss
france quand une miss france nue
téléphonait pas où la prenais pas de
faire de telle ou telle chose tout le
temps s métier en avant ou et puis moi
y'a un truc terrible que j'ai envie de
dire à l'antenne à la quand même vendu
le faire part de mon mariage
non oui à france dimanche au cices
thouars ah oui 90 c'est pour ça que
chaque femme a commencé à l'avant du
lavandou acquis pour mon mariage je
l'avais pas invitée parce qu'on était en
discorde et elle m'avait supplié de
l'inviter je dis non je vous inviterai
pas un point final et j'avais invité son
ami
et j'ai su par son ami qu'elle avait
piqué le faire part de mon mariage chez
sa copine et bizarrement le lendemain ça
a été mis sur france dimanche
donc qu'est c'est gros c'est donc alors
j'en ai marre qu'on me dise oui vous
êtes passé un pac-man de fontenay elle a
fait tellement de choses tout oui je
l'aï remercié elle a été comme ma
deuxième mère je les adorais mais elle
m'a fait trop de coups bas et plein de
choses que je passe que je peux pas dire
à l'antenne des plaisirs des raisons la
première pour l'audience valu bien crado
d'auge et en sortir une telle chose
quand quand j'en ai fait la trame
célébrité quand j'avais fait la ferme
célébrités qu'on m'avait raconté une
histoire avec du cru et sans effet 66
couverture et c'est vrai que j'avais
plus envie de téléphoner à qui que ce
soit enfin j'étais enfermée chez moi ça
a été l'horreur et comme j'y parlais pas
voulu parler aussi à la téléphoné à
france dimanche pour dire à nathalie la
à la une cervelle de pois chiches et
surtout tout ce qu'elle sait faire c'est
se faire culbuter dans les deux fois
alors jean-pierre alors je vous presse
le cube but et c'est vraiment très
ancien et l'agent pierre il était fou
furieux
hilary son téléphone qu'il l'a eu et
relais aux téléphones pour la remettre à
sa place
donc chaque fois des petites choses
comme ça on croit que c'est une sainte
nitouche ok je peux comprendre
elle est âgée elle est si la mach 1 au
retour
elle a beaucoup d'argent est là une
magnifique vie elle a voyagé toute sa
vie dans le monde entier la mois elle a
été dans des restaurants extraordinaire
alors rencontré plein de gens
elle a la chance d'avoir une famille de
l'argent il ya plein de gens dehors qui
crèvent la faim qui ont besoin de
bouffer alors se plaindre par rapport
que sa vie elle est fixée
non faut la foire été fait d'un petit
message doit maintenant très simple soit
oublie pas rond geneviève thème ta
gueule par exemple
plaisante geneviève arrêtez de nous
casser les couilles
mais qu'est ce qu'elle est vulgaire la
marque ea mais qu est-ce qu avec l ai
pas vu le gars parce que j'en ai un
ras-le-bol et stop
et si vous alliez foire et de la plus
tapés dessus parce qu elle est adorable
fait tout ce qu'elle peut et en plus
dans le livre sylvie tellier qu'on le
dit pas mais faut arrêter c'est bien
c'est bien non on a bien commencé